voting in Chicago is kind of a racial
census and always has been Paul Salas
the guy who lost narrowly lost in this
election is the latest in a long line of
liberal white reformers in Chicago who
can't get elected and valis is a
household name in Chicago because he ran
the Chicago Public Schools he was
appointed by Mayor Daley and Daley ran
the Chicago machine it was corrupt but
he ran it with some nod at least toward
the idea that residents deserve some
value for their services and he
appointed Valles to clean up Chicago
Public Schools he did a pretty decent
job obviously they're still not great
but you just can't win running in a
general election in Chicago like that
the only reason Rahm Emanuel did is he
was seen as Obama's surrogate in Chicago
and that's why he got elected so my
prediction was if the university sector
is going to vote for Brandon Johnson
and the black neighborhoods are going to
vote for whichever candidate who's
running is black and the white
neighborhoods are going to vote for
whichever candidate is white it's going
to be Brandon Johnson who wins because
the tiebreaker goes to the far left
extremists